in the meantime we'll speak to Marcos
Walt he's the chief Economist at ADM
investor Services joins me now from
London good to have you with us on the
program let's just begin with Rishi
sunak's comments of the country will
experience profound economic challenges
he seems to be preparing the ground for
some pretty difficult choices for not
only his government and a reality the
the British public will find difficult
perhaps to swallow in the coming weeks
yes he does I mean you know there are
profound economic challenges
um the cost of living and energy crisis
which is not only gripping the UK but
also
um more
broader problems for the UK economy uh
labor shortages due to skills shortages
um and the general challenges of
managing that transition through away
from the EU so these are all actually
sort of confluencing for the time being
and making that even more difficult and
indeed um you know inflation is hovering
around 10 percent uh we haven't seen
that for a couple of decades in the UK
add to that the fact that he also has to
try and you know mend a fractured Tory
party but in terms of the fiscal
responsibility
um it's all very well to talk about
spending but you have to rejuvenate the
economy and to do that you either have
to I presume save money or it requires
cash injections
where are those cash injections going to
come from are we looking at corporate
windfall taxes or is the public expected
to pay for all of this the money has to
come from somewhere
well that that's sort of partially the
problem that what's being mooted before
he won
um is that Mr Hunt would basically
extend the energy windfall tax which is
actually not um necessarily that
positive because the more you tax the
energy companies the less likely they
are to invest and in business investment
is precisely what the UK needs it's very
sluggish uh the second thing which is
being proposed is uh uh tax on a winfall
tax on the banking sector uh largely
because uh there is a feeling that
they're not passing on the increased
rates that are happening in the UK to
save us but then again they're already
taxed quite highly and you you know in a
situation of rising interest rates you
don't want to then actually hobble the
availability of credit to the UK economy
and of course you know austerity is not
a word that the current government wants
to bring back into the conversation but
it might well be banded around and that
the public response was very negative to
it under the former a conservative
Chancellor George Osborne but you know
it it perhaps is an inevitability isn't
it
um well there's a certain amount of it
um but you you have to also be very very
careful here I think the one proposal
which Mr sunac made while he was still
previously Chancellor was that the
measures to actually support
um the the consumer sector in terms of
the energy crisis should be targeted
those on Lower incomes uh which was not
the case with mistrustless proposals and
that's basically going to have to be the
the thrust of whatever they do where
there are going to be cut backs it
really needs to ensure uh that you're
not harming the lowest in people on the
lowest incomes in society who already
stretched to their absolute limits Mark
just bear with me for one second we've
just got some breaking news now coming
in that tarishi sunak has been appointed
as the British prime minister he's been
given that permission by King Charles
III to form the next government and of
course we will get more on that as we
see Mr sunak leave Buckingham Palace
Mark obviously we do now officially have
a new prime minister Rishi sunak in the
days of covid and during the pandemic
used a very much a a big state approach
in in terms of looking after the
community at large somewhat perhaps
sensitive unheard offer perhaps a
conservative Chancellor unusual for
conservative to spend spend spend we
suddenly tend to think of the labor
party having that sort of trait do you
think that could be something that we
may see more of Prime Minister sunac
doing in the weeks ahead you know the
the big approach uh to help all sectors
of British Society
um there's going to be limits now I
think we all should we ought to remember
that actually as Chancellor he was
pressured by other members of the
government not to be quite so Hasty so
as much as he oversaw a lot of spending
during covet he was trying to earn end
the Thurlow scheme
a lot earlier than what's going to be
necessary and some of the other
forbearance measures
um so he is you know he is on the
hawkish side so as much as I expect to
see some increased spending I think it
is going to be rather limited and that's
going to be the biggest challenge for
the UK economy because mistrust wasn't
wrong we in the in the point that the UK
really does need a good Kickstart to its
economy because it really is lagging a
lot of its G7 peers
and of course at the end of the day the
markets are very clear about how they
feel there's been a slight you might say
Improvement encouragement of the
appointment of uh Rishi sunak what
should we be looking at in the coming
either weeks or months into the way the
government are approaching the economy
here in the UK and how the markets are
reacting to them because obviously
they're intertwined
yes I mean there's two aspects to it one
they will really want to see that the
conservative party
um is acting uh in in a unified way if
there is any
Resurgence of the sort of backstabbing
we saw both under Mr Johnson and
obviously under mistrust
um that confidence which is being or
that benefit of the doubt which is being
given to Mr sunac at the moment will
soon evaporate the second thing
um is going to be how the you know how
the public react and how the
conservative backbenchers also react to
the measures which are announced because
if they sound basically that like the UK
is going to have to go through a long
period which is quite stagflationary
where there isn't much in the way of
stimulus for the economy and there are
increasing burdens both for businesses
even if it's particular businesses and
consumers
um the the Resurgence of this Unity
seems to me very very likely we should
see what happened and certainly for the
time being it's been good to speak to
you mark Oswald there from ADM investor
services in London thank you very much
for your time
Let's cross over to Andrew Simmons in
Downing Street and Andrew obviously
we're breaking the news now that we're
hearing uh that Rishi sunak has been
appointed by King Charles III to form
his Majesty's government
bride he is prime minister officially
now and he'll be getting in his car his
limousine uh very soon uh in fact only
minutes away to drive uh over here to
his new home number 10 Downing streets
the third prime minister uh the UK has
had in only 50 days quite a remarkable
sequence of events he has a massive task
ahead of him in actual fact normally at
this stage you would see crowds
Gathering lots of MPS gathering at both
ends of Downing Street on this occasion
there is no one here in the way of other
than the media simply because there's
been an order put out for MPS not to be
hand clapping at their new prime
minister on arrival at Downing streets
because this is a serious rather somber
occasion where the economy is in a
dangerous trouble and the mood has to be
contrite that has to be that this is the
word that's coming out that MPS must be
very focused on listening to their new
leader
outline what lies ahead and that doesn't
sound good it sounds as if there's going
to be more belt tightening and there
certainly sounds as if uh Rishi sunak is
going to get tough uh tougher than Liz
truss in many ways and possibly tougher
than the uh the stand-in Chancellor the
Finance Minister Jeremy Hunt has been in
outlining a whole raft of measures that
reversed what trust wanted to do now
trust when she left uh spelled out
exactly what she'd wanted to do she
tried to make things sound positive in
the sense that some of her measures were
executed National Insurance for example
are being cut down somewhat and the
energy
um program of sub of subsidies for
British people but then she really
didn't say sorry and it was in a way a
defiant sort of speech uh she was fluent
it seemed that she was quite relaxed
about her departure but then she left uh
without that apology so really right now
everyone is waiting here for Rishi sunak
to arrive and to spell out exactly what
he plans to do
soon he'll be driving out of Buckingham
Palace and Anita we'll come back to you
in Downing Street as of when he arrives
and when he speaks to Andrew Simmons
there for us in Daven Street